[Music]
every game has something the players
love to complain about in terms of
balancing counter-strike has pistols
dota has enchantress as passive and
don't even get me started about League
of Legends but in siege people don't so
much cry about the guns or the gadgets
or the operators as much as they do the
maps whether you're queueing into an
ongoing match on yachts or just
wondering what the hell happened with
the hair effort rework there is a good
chance that you've found yourself
complaining about the areas on which we
siege heads throw down so ready those
cursors over the return to menu button
and start praying for Bank because we
are about to count down the top 10 worst
maps in Rainbow six siege kicking off
our list we have what is arguably the
most awful map in siege Bartlett [ __ ]
University the only reason this map
isn't higher on our list is because it
should never have seen PvP play to begin
with oh you're inside you
[Music]
upstairs is clear originally designed
for sieges PvE co-op mode Article five
Bartlett was rejigged for PvP at the
behest of the community it was for a PvE
mode in these situations it was the
eleventh situation of the game who
despite Ubisoft's many warnings that the
map wasn't suitable for multiplayer were
eager to give it a go man were they
misguided listen even even if you win
the game on Bartlett you lose okay
there's no winners I'm barley anyone
that's playing on Bartlett automatically
is at a loss needless to say the map was
a certifiable nightmare in addition to
having only one door Bartlett was famous
for its spawn piece thankfully it was
removed from both ranked and casual play
in patch 3 point 1.0 and is currently
the only map that's been removed from
all rotations coming in number 9 is good
old theme park contrary to what you
might expect theme park isn't known for
being a happy-go-lucky place where
players experience feelings of childlike
Glee
it's a rundown convoluted and oversized
deathtrap where dreams go to die
attractions include target shooting the
beanbag toss and operator cutouts where
the whole family can gather for a
photo-op praise be to Papa ooh be that
this map is finally being taken out of
ranking the eighth spot on our list is
one of the blandest and most
aggravatingly linear maps in all of
siege fortress aside from the fact that
it boasts virtually no vertical play
everything looks exactly the same
making call-outs maddeningly ineffective
go ahead try telling one of your
teammates that their opponents on white
stairs and see which of the three they
run to
[Music]
[Music]
props to OB for taking this map out of
ranked as well coming in at number seven
is chalet one of the most hated maps in
the history of competitive siege it's
absurdly attacker sided given that
bandit tricking is basically impossible
there's a zillion external windows and
rotations are extremely difficult to
execute as a result can you study can
you shut
[Music]
honestly the only way for the defenders
to win is to do [ __ ] like this to think
that this used to be a prolene map
[Music]
taking the six spot on our list is the
odds the closest thing siege has ever
seen to hell freezing over there's
nothing worse than queuing into casual
for a quick warmup before you play your
ranked game and finding yourself down to
nothing on what is quite literally a
sinking ship don't kid yourself the only
reason you even play this map is because
you're too lazy to return to menu
[Music]
coming in at the halfway point in our
list is sieges very own spawn killers
paradise old canal from the cross map
window peaks to the rooftop run outs
every time you approach the actual
building it feels like you're trying to
storm the beaches of Normandy okay thank
you for lining up today thank the Lord
to chunka that Ubisoft finally decided
to rework this map even if the new one
is in need of defeat
[Music]
taking the fourth spot on our list is
none other than new he referred the only
map to ever get worse after its rework
Harrison
okay so Hereford rework was a dumpster
fire
[Music]
it's dark dreary impossible to see
enemies in and it's top floor is the
most unassailable bomb site in all of
siege it's a dread filled dumpster where
gadgets mean nothing and attackers have
no choice but to sell their souls to
lion Blackbeard and Blair coming in at
number three is every ranked players
worst nightmare
skyscraper what happens on the
skyscraper isn't actually rainbow
succeeds it's some sick variation game
that I don't really enjoy that that's
that's brutal but I just all the windows
all the balconies on skyscraper you're
always seems like every gun fight takes
place like through a window or a door
from outside to in and I like the newer
maps where they give kind of buffer
rooms around the objectives and allow
you like get inside and you know clear
corners and stuff like that so
skyscraper by far my least favorite map
in the game to this day skyscraper
remains the most claustrophobic map and
see [ __ ] what's all [ __ ]
[Music]
come on it's up to my window guys you're
not covering anything no that's [ __ ]
garbage you put me on the records I
don't even care I'll say that anyone I
literally tweet it out almost weekly
[ __ ] skyscraper then I'm sorry it's not
even the skyscraper is the worst map and
see it's that it's the worst map to last
this long and ranked even after taking
out hair referred fortress and theme
park movie soft decided to leave
skyscraper in the rotation making it the
most groan inducing map to lose élow on
taking the penultimate spot on our list
is a map that defies all expectations as
to what a siege map should be Tower I
think it's the worst map they've ever
designed it has no vertical play it is
huge defenders have a field day roaming
on it I there's not a lot of setups you
can do in it that makes it unique
there's like no birth diversity you know
you set it up I hate it hey I despise it
with a passion I know it feels like a
different game when you play on Tower
and that's why I despise it in terms of
layout there's no question that no map
inspires the sheer unadulterated rage
the tower does just think about it it's
like you're playing a weird Call of Duty
meets battlefield hybrid except with a
boatload of siege mechanics that really
have no bearing on the outcome of the
match roamers have free rein attackers
can camp balconies that defenders don't
even have access to and in addition to
having virtually zero vertical play it
is impossible to navigate and/or drone
tower is where siege goes to die
that was a headshot what what happens
when you make a siege map that's almost
completely destructible the one and only
[ __ ] favela
no I'm gonna try to cover the premise of
favela was simple make it so that nearly
every external wall can be claimed
rattled and banged the result was a
[ __ ] the likes of which siege had
never seen before
easy literally easy to fall killed my
life a mean fest in which strats are
irrelevant and glitches run-outs
recruit rushes and tachanka turrets are
the norm you are the [ __ ] well guys
that's it those are the top 10 worst
maps in rainbow 6 siege be sure to LIKE
the video subscribe to our Channel and
let us know in the comments whether you
think skyscraper should still be in the
ranked pool see you next time thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]